الشرطة الإسرائيلية تستخدم الهراوات لضرب
الحشود التي تحمل نعش
صحفية الجزيرة شيرين أبو عكلي بينما
تجمع الآلاف في
موكب جنازتها ، قُتلت أبو عجلي بالرصاص يوم
الأربعاء أثناء تغطيتها
للغارات العسكرية الإسرائيلية في
أتيكو شوبرت بالضفة الغربية تعيش في القدس
وأنتيك  ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا عما
تراه على الأرض هناك هذا
الصباح ،
نعم أنا في الواقع في مقبرة جبل صهيون
وقد وصل موكب الجنازة
للتو إذا كنت سأقوم
بتدوير الكاميرا هنا قليلاً  يمكنك
أن
ترى التابوت يحمل الآن أه
شيرين
أه ويمكنك أن ترى هناك الكثير من الناس
قد أتوا إلى هنا
اليوم للحزن
عليها وإبداء احترامهم
وتضامنهم معها وعملها.
يوم عاطفي للغاية ،
خرج الآلاف من
الفلسطينيين لإظهار
دعمهم لها ، لقد كنا في الواقع في وقت سابق
في مستشفى سانت جوزيف حيث
كان جسدها يتم تحضيره و  هنا كانت عائلتها
تنتظر أه كانوا يأملون أن يكون
موكب الجنازة من هناك
يسيرون بها إلى طريقها إلى
الكنيسة ثم إلى هنا لكن الشرطة الإسرائيلية
لم تسمح بذلك وعندما حاولوا
القيام بذلك تحركت الشرطة الإسرائيلية
بالغاز المسيل للدموع والفلاش  القنابل اليدوية
لتفريق المعزين الذين
هاجموا في وقت ما حاملي
النعش الذين كانوا يحملون
النعش وكاد التابوت أن يسقط
، كان الوضع متوترًا للغاية
ومع ذلك تدخلت الأسرة واتخذت قرارًا
بعدم القيام بالموكب الجنائزي من
هناك وهناك
شرطة إسرائيلية  ثم عدت من
أرض المستشفى أه قام بتسجيل العديد من
الأشخاص ولكن سُمح للعائلة
بالخروج والسماح لها بالاستمرار في هذا
الموكب الجنائزي ، فما
تراه الآن
هو آلاف الأشخاص الذين
جاءوا للانضمام في حداد
شريف.
ولذا فهم يتدفقون من مدينة القدس القديمة ،
فهم يواصلون
القدوم ويمكنك أن ترى هناك علمًا فلسطينيًا
مهمًا للغاية لأننا نعرف
من  الأسرة أنه طُلب منهم في الواقع
عدم عرض
السلام الفلسطيني الذي كان طلبًا خاصًا ، ولكن كما
يمكنك أن تتخيل ، من الصعب جدًا
السيطرة على هذه الحشود وقد رأينا الآن
العلم الفلسطيني يرفرف
طوال موكب الجنازة
إليك